[Music]
wow
what did i just watch el camino
christmas
supposedly a christmas comedy was one of
the
strangest off-putting and confusing
movie experiences i've ever had in my
life the movie decides to have a weird
opening
where it's your classic let's show the
end scene to open
and then go back to it and find out how
we got there the problem here is they
showed dak shepard
against a cop car at a hostage situation
and
his part of the story and where that
exact moment continues later on at the
end of the movie
really isn't that crazy that just begins
the whole tone of this movie that
nothing really makes any sense it is the
exact
feeling of watching a student film that
is not very good they decided to send us
to the random 39 hours earlier number
we're introduced to the mysterious
character of eric played by nick grimes
who is looking for his father and then
we're introduced to jessica albo maybe
the most important character in the
movie the reporter who has no backstory
is pregnant
and just wants to get a good story that
gets massive coverage out there
and right away in the beginning my
friend was watching the movie with they
said
is this a comedy what kind of movie is
this you're both trying to figure out
is it supposed to be making fun of
itself is it supposed to make you laugh
honestly or is it even trying to do any
of that is it is it just a drama and is
it a christmas movie
because all they're doing is throwing in
references to christmas or putting
a christmas decoration here and there
but it doesn't have the feel of that at
all
i didn't laugh once in this entire movie
i laughed in the sense of how bad it was
i didn't laugh with it i laughed at it
but
looking at it from that angle there's a
lot of funny stuff here to kind of
jab on when we meet the female lead the
mom who has mommy issues
she's at the diner and the character of
eric sends her a piece of cake
like it's a slick move and then when she
looks out the window to see who did it
he has a most serious look on his face
it was a piece of cake
you're not james bond that was really
really off
and again a perfect example of a scene
that you don't know that's supposed to
be am i supposed to be laughing at this
or
what the hell was that and then when we
see the female lead again
eric runs into her at her job she's has
her back to the registers doing her
homework studying
but is shocked that someone approached
her even though she should be working
right or at least facing the direction
of customers so
she's acting like someone just came into
her room and intruded in no sense and
she's extremely mean in the scene which
was just odd because the rest of the
movie she's not
that mean and he says the best line what
are you studying and she says
what are you a cop how does it make any
sense
i didn't know that that's a classic cop
question what are you studying i
literally was just like
what how does that translate both
writers of this movie this is their
first big writing gig so you can tell
immediately i don't think anyone
proofread or looked over
the script i think they were just trying
to get paychecks for everyone here
netflix right now is focused on quantity
and not quality which is a big
problem and they're pushing all these
movies out paying these stars they're
willing to do it for the money and just
shooting out a lot of scripts so
if you write scripts you might have a
shot at getting a netflix movie because
they're taking whatever they can get to
acknowledge the elephant in the room
the christmas movie master tim allen is
in this movie
probably the biggest sell to that
audience who'd actually watch this movie
like myself because i'm reviewing it of
course but the best thing about his
introduction
is when he meets eric he's not letting
him into the apartment room there's
always confusion and when eric walks
away from the door the shot in the
background tim allen in like a second
appears
on the other side of the apartment
building and out the window and says hey
you want to get a drink
how'd he get there so fast what kind of
shot was that that did not make any
sense in time he must have
sprinted as fast as usain bolt going
from
his apartment room to the deck on the
other side of the building
again was i supposed to laugh at this
because it made me laugh hysterically
and then as we get to know tim allen's
character he's your old vietnam vet
boozing away and smoking pot i feel like
tim allen was really excited about the
script god and was like
yes this is my bad santa roll because
he's always a good character in these
christmas movies he's in goofy and now
he knew i can be serious with it
be cool and it was just an awful
performance on his part i'm not someone
against tim allen
trust me but this is why he hasn't been
cast in a role like this before and the
camera shots in the bar scene with him
were
really bad this was probably the worst
shots i noticed in the movie
because in the scene he's talking to
nick shots are game from the side
the focus is on the back of tim allen's
head and their mouths are like in the
front of the screen so it's really weird
it really feels like very amateur
filmmaking all around writing directing
acting and camera work and there's a lot
of good actors in here and other stuff
but in this they're really just
mailing it in i hope at least because if
they're trying not good then vincent
d'onofrio's character
the other partner of dak shepard is a
cop he has some moments where he's just
over the top angry that's not believable
even in a very scary cop like that for
example when they're interrogating
nick axe shepherd says to the character
carl played by vincent d'onofrio
merry christmas he goes don't say that
it's so forced and just not natural like
why is he so angry that he said merry
christmas right there even if someone
doesn't like christmas just didn't make
any sense and then when they show the
shot after where tim allen's getting
beaten up by the kids from the bar
the actual punches and the actual
kicking of him you could clearly tell
they're not hitting him
him on the ground and you see a kick
throw and he just reacts like he got hit
but we didn't actually see the foot hit
the body so again very laughable and
then it cuts to tim allen
in his apartment alone he takes a sip of
a little teeny weeny
whiskey bottle serious piano music's
playing there's no set design in the
apartment by the way it's just blank
white walls
and he throws a liquor bottle supposed
to be serious and dramatic i was crying
my eyes out at this point in particular
and if this was a movie in theaters this
is the part i would walk
out of the theater it felt like threat
level midnight
from the office you've never seen the
office that's an episode of the office
michael scott steve curl's character
shows his movie he's been working on for
years and it's completely awful and over
the top
cheesy corny it felt like i was watching
that then we cut to jessica alba at a
play
all right she's in this movie the most
important character and the best part to
wrap up jessica alba's part of this
movie
was at the end where she finally gets
that nationwide shot she's gonna get
and she's going into labor that chat was
hysterical where they're all picking her
up and she's like ah
this is happening all this whole hostage
situation is going on
you don't know nothing about her still
the whole point of her character was to
get jessica album this movie
but really annoyed me when they were all
in the hot situation that's when the
movie got even worse and you think it
would get better
and they're all really hard on the cop
yeah he's not a nice cop
he's a bad dude but they're giving guy
who's holding them hostage eric
really clear pass and look he's telling
them he's innocent and stuff but
okay i'd say i don't care you're
innocent let me go this isn't my problem
you know so i'd be really mad at him too
and then they're all like on his side
and they're like yelling at the cop and
they're all getting like sympathetic to
him in a situation where this again this
guy is holding them hostage then when
they decide to listen to that mean old
cop in the liquor store
the funniest part of this movie he looks
at the store owner
who had no purpose in this movie
whatsoever and he's like remember when i
took care of your sick wife
and then he says to the girl remember
when i ran your abusive boyfriend
out of town i still don't know how you
even do that as a cop someone
hits the girlfriend but you get them out
of town literally like don't come back
here
doesn't make sense so over the top corny
she starts crying and then he goes to
the drunk tim
allen and you had your vietnam sob
stories doesn't say though what he
helped him with and throughout this
again they're just throwing in random
christmas references and tim allen's
sole purpose a lot of these scenes is
just to throwing well it's christmas or
merry christmas and then he breaks out
into song at one point and again my
friend who's watching moving me
suggested hey i think they're gonna
shoot him here which i thought would be
hysterical like yeah good call that
would be funny but
they didn't try to be funny here they
just let him sing and then he sat down
missed opportunity but again
in netflix's menu this is labeled as a
comedy
i didn't laugh with the movie at all
once
it was always just at and then when nick
comes to his senses
and he's basically going to surrender
and let them out why didn't the cop in
the liquor store and the cause outside
just let him do that when they're on the
walkie-talkie communicating the next
step the cop is not walking talking if
he just said
look we're good we're all coming out
just be on with it we don't need to have
them just shoot blindly knowing there's
a kid in there it's ridiculous
and if that's supposed to be the funny
part of it and like ironic you have to
make that clearer
even when you have all these dumb cops
and the humor as i get it that they're
dumb
and stupid like doc shepard's character
for example but it's not clear enough
he's not dumb enough even it's just
okay he's an idiot but it's not funny
they're not making it funny
and the best was tim allen got his spot
where he got that nice monologue
about christmas in nam in 1969.
for me maybe i missed the line in the
beginning or got the wrong vibe with
this but
it just sneaks in that he's his dad and
this is what he's been looking for
he says the best quote that really stuck
with me no ask is too big for the spirit
of the holidays
because we all pray to that spirit of
the holidays wherever he may be
and he sacrifices himself and he's our
hero
it's such a tear-jerking moment not
really it didn't do anything for me was
supposed to do that
and what scares me i looked on twitter
of people's reactions to this movie and
there was people saying that
they cried their eyes out at the end no
you didn't you just loved him alan
maybe you cried your house because you
love the guy and you're seeing an actor
you're like
it's not real but him being dead there
was hard to watch but there's no way
this story made you feel that way and
when you think the movie's over right
there
we get to go to the 182 days later
another random number
to see how everyone's been and dak
shepard's character
is running for sheriff don't care and
then the best reveal was when the store
owner is on the beach
and he's still alive and if you've seen
threat level midnight it reminds me
of when they reveal michael scott is
actually michael scarn
narrating the whole movie still alive
and well the same feeling
so cheesy review like yeah he only shot
me six times but i
who knew you could survive that what
like me and my friend we were like
that's where we just completely lost it
i was like is this an snl sketch
and again his character just like
jessica albus had no point to be
in this movie the props in this movie
served more purpose and then at the end
we don't get the cheesy kiss we're all
waiting for
to feel the vibe of this movie eric sees
the girl and she's with her son and the
sun's
cock-blocking and that's the end so
overall this was
the worst movie i reviewed this year it
is not a christmas movie so don't be
fooled by that unless you believe
a christmas movie is just having tim
allen in it and hearing him sing some
jingles here and there
sure then maybe it is for you so maybe
look at his spoof it's worth the watch
and it's not a good drama so it's just a
waste of time i'm gonna give it a two
that's the lowest i've given anything
show movie podcast trailer just a2
but you can only go up from here please
leave your comments below if you agree
with me on any of this
disagree maybe you liked it maybe i'm
crazy please let me know down below what
you think but
el camino christmas meant to you please
subscribe
to see more movie reviews tv reviews
celebrity interviews
trailer reactions and much more please
follow me at steverly1 on twitter and
instagram and keep coming back